the past six months have been to put it
mildly a very difficult time for the
country first the Democrats dragged the
nation through the phony impeachment
proceedings without even specifying a
crime then the coronavirus hit and blew
state governors decided to flatten the
curve by flattening our economy and our
constitutional rights and now we're in
the midst of mass demonstrations and
still some rioting breaking out in major
cities and with the 2020 election now
just four and a half months away or so
the GOP has to make sure its platform
actually speaks to the horrors and the
hardship that this country is
experiencing it should also give people
hope that our best days are indeed ahead
of us they're not behind us well lucky
for them the Ingraham angle has put
together some platform prerequisites
first we will redouble our efforts to
preserve for all Americans their freedom
of speech freedom of religion freedom of
press and freedom of assembly we lost a
lot more than just our booming economy
in those lockdowns and even with states
reopening millions of Americans are
still unable to attend church services
go to weddings or any other large
gatherings for that matter well unless
you're looting rioting or hurling
obscenities the cops of course then it's
okay our sacrosanct freedoms should only
be abridged in true emergencies and only
pursuant to laws passed by elected
officials not by decrees issued by
governor's or mayor's especially those
who don't even follow their own rules
Chicago's mayor Lori Lightfoot is
spotted breaking social distancing to
get a haircut
governor Pritzker in Illinois says his
family to Florida the play on their
estate and then locks down the whole
state and tells them what they can't do
while Governor Whitmer was urging
residents to stay at home over Memorial
Day weekend the governor's husband Mark
Mallory is pushing to get his boat in
the water
Mallory tried to name-drop the governor
to get it done number two we want
prosperity for all Americans and to
achieve this goal we will protect basic
property rights but we will also stop
efforts by
multinational companies to ship jobs
offshore think about it 21 million
Americans almost are drawing on
unemployment right now
and while the jobless rate is coming
down as states reopened the numbers are
unacceptable so instead of Congress just
green-lighting more debt funded welfare
benefits Congress should make sure
American workers do not have to compete
unfairly with foreign workers now
Trump's already done the unimaginable by
bringing China to the negotiating table
with tariffs and by replacing the
disaster that was NAFTA with the u.s.
MCA
but we need to do a lot more and we
could start by bringing back our medical
supply chains from China the country of
course that Unleashed kovat on the rest
of the world never again should we be
held hostage by the CCP for vital
medical equipment and medications now
when the next pandemic hits and of
course it will they should be coming to
us for help not the other way around
third we want all Americans to feel safe
inside and outside their homes and that
means Swift and sure punishment for
violent crime especially in poor
neighborhoods
it also means supporting the men and
women who put their lives on the line
every day to protect us stop treating us
like animals and bugs and start treating
us with some respect nobody talks about
all the police officers that were killed
in the last week in the United States of
America we already know what happens
when blue lives no longer matter we see
tragedies like the cold-blooded murder
of retired captain David Dorn in st.
Louis or the three officers in Buffalo
who were run over by a peaceful
protester in an SUV
an officer Shaima Colonus in Las Vegas
who was shot in the head during a
peaceful protest and he may be on a
ventilator for the rest of his life not
even 30 years old now no police
department is perfect and bad cops
should be weeded out cops that commit
criminal actions should be jailed the
punishment should be severe but
defunding police because of the evil
acts of a very small number is dangerous
we already know what a police freeze
society
looks like response times for crimes in
progress were over 15 minutes about
three times as long as the average of
every year if that is your mother your
sister your cousin your neighbor's kid
that is being raped robbed assaulted and
otherwise victimized you're not gonna
want to have to report that it took the
police three times longer to get there
number four we recognize that the
Chinese Communist Party is a grave
threat to the United States and will
take all measures necessary to prevent
it from endangering our national
interests now for starters we should
prohibit American companies from doing
any work in China that would benefit the
Chinese military or enable the communist
regime to further oppress its own
citizens tech companies we're talking to
you we absolutely need to keep the
Chinese from infiltrating and
undermining our institutions of higher
learning and that means no more CCP
funding for American universities but
let's go a step further and pass
legislation recently proposed by Senator
Tom cotton
it's a scandal me that we have trained
so many of the Chinese Communist Party's
brightest minds to go back to China to
compete for our jobs to take our
business and ultimately to steal our
property and design weapons and other
devices that can be used against the
American people so I think we need to
take a very hard look at the visas that
we give to Chinese nationals to come to
the United States to study number five
we believe that America remains the best
hope for a better life and a better
world and we pledge to teach our
children the truth about this country
both the good and the bad and to
encourage them to honor the sacrifices
of all those patriots who came before us
we've got to teach history based not on
what's in fashion but what's important
if we forget what we did we won't know
who we are now finally we know that
freedom requires a fighting spirit
tyrants both large and small hate this
country they hate its people and the
freedoms they want to force us to live
under rules that
make up while they'll be free to do as
they want left unchecked they'll create
a divided country and a divided world
with the rulers enjoying special
privileges and the ruled well you'll
just be trampled ever since the days of
the revolution average Americans have
fought against the sword of tyranny and
we pledged to continue this fight no
matter the odds and to give our children
and grandchildren of all races and
creeds a freer and better world both
here and abroad and that's the angle